do you know how insane it sounds to even  say that a cement provider landed a  six-figure contract from a tick tock  here are producing three pieces of tick  tock video a day for their business and  if you raise your hand I'm going to  check on stage publicly so don't lie  I already have dozens of emails from  lawyers contractors a cement provider  hit me up last week that he landed a big  contract from a tick tock do you know  how insane it sounds to even say that a  cement provider landed a six-figure  contract from a tick tock it's a reality  are you challenging yourself to do  branding work because branding is the  singular thing that grows anything it's  just the way the world works and so I  think the opportunity is extraordinary